This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a scene in the buddy-cut movie Rush Hour 2, starring Jackie Chan and Chris Tucker, that takes place in a Las Vegas casino. What's that letting you, Mouse? In the scene, Jackie Chan's character is in the unenviable predicament of having a small bomb stuffed inside his mouth by a villain. I hate it when that happens. Jackie Chan's mouth is taped shut, his hands are tied, he shoved onto the floor of the
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。在由成龙和克里斯·塔克（Chris Tucker）主演的动作喜剧电影《尖峰时刻 2》（Rush Hour 2）中，有一个场景发生在拉斯维加斯的一个赌场里。那是给你的，莫斯（Mouse）？在这个场景中，成龙饰演的角色陷入了一种令人羡慕的绝境：一个反派把一颗小型炸弹塞进了他的嘴里。我最讨厌这种事发生了。成龙的嘴被胶带封住，双手被绑，他被推倒在
casino about to explode. Fortunately, at the last minute, Jackie Chan's partner, played by Chris Tucker, removes the tape from Chan's mouth and Chan spits the bomb onto a new bi-relet table, where it goes on. So in that scene where the Roulette Table explodes, money flies everywhere. Best producer Elizabeth Nakano. And to create the scene and a bunch of others in the movie, filmmakers needed a lot of money. Fake money. We had produced a billion dollars of $100 bills, which is quite a bit of money.
赌场地板上，即将发生爆炸。幸运的是，在最后一分钟，由克里斯·塔克饰演的成龙搭档撕掉了成龙嘴上的胶带，成龙把炸弹吐到了一张崭新的双零轮盘赌桌上，炸弹随即爆炸了。所以在这个轮盘赌桌爆炸的场景中，钱到处飞溅。最佳制作人伊丽莎白·中野（Elizabeth Nakano）。为了拍摄这个场景以及电影中的其他许多场景，电影制作者需要大量的钱。假钱。我们制作了价值十亿美元的面值为 100 美元的钞票，这是一大笔钱。
It's 14 palette loads of $100 bills solid 4 foot by 4 foot cubes. That's Greg Vilsen Jr. He's the CEO of ISS Props, the company that provided all the fake money for the movie. And he says, while they were filming Rush Hour 2, something strange happened. A couple of men showed up to Vilsen's office. Well, when they showed up, they were saying that they were from secret service and provided documents indicating such, and I thought it was being punk. I didn't believe that it was a real situation.
那是 14 板面额 100 美元的钞票，是实打实的 4 英尺乘 4 英尺的正方体。那是格雷格·威尔森二世（Greg Vilsen Jr.）。他是 ISS Props 公司的首席执行官，这家公司为这部电影提供了所有的假钱。他说，在《尖峰时刻 2》拍摄期间，发生了一件奇怪的事情。几个人来到了威尔森的办公室。嗯，当他们出现时，他们自称是特勤局人员，并提供了相应的证件，我当时以为是在搞恶作剧。我不相信那是真实的状况。
Do you remember how many people there were? Just two officers, but it got very serious, a very real, very fast. The secret service was in Greg Billson's office because during the filming of that scene in the casino, some of the fake cash had gone missing. Some souvenir seekers and extras grabbed some of that money put it in their pocket and it subsequently started turning up his counterfeit over the next few days. People were trying to use the fake money as real money up and down the Las Vegas strip, which meant that Greg was being accused by the Secret Service of counterfeiting.
你还记得当时有多少人吗？只有两名警官，但情况变得非常严肃，而且非常真实、非常迅速。特勤局出现在格雷格·比尔森（Greg Billson）的办公室里，因为在拍摄赌场那个场景时，一些道具现金不见了。一些纪念品搜寻者和群众演员把其中一些钱放进口腔（口袋），随后在接下来的几天里，这些钱开始作为假钞出现。人们开始在拉斯维加斯大道的各处试图把这些假钱当成真钱使用，这意味着格雷格被特勤局指控伪造货币。
This is a serious charge. People who counterfeit money can face large fines and even jail time, which has made the use of prop money in movies really complicated over the years. We have pretty strict laws around the reproduction of US currency, which can be traced back to the mid-1800s. Around the time of the Civil War, there was a ton of counterfeit currency circulating in the United States. Some people say anywhere from the third to a half of all money was fake. The federal government wanted to give people faith in its currency. So, it got serious about cracking down on counterfeit money.
这是一项严重的指控。伪造货币的人可能面临巨额罚款甚至监禁，这使得电影中使用道具钱在过去几年里变得非常复杂。我们围绕美国货币的复制有着相当严格的法律，这可以追溯到 19 世纪中叶。大约在南北战争时期，美国流通着大量的假币。有人说，所有货币中有三分之一到一半是假币。联邦政府希望人们对它的货币建立信心。因此，它开始认真打击假币。
All reproductions of US currency became illegal, including photographs of money. Along with the law that criminalized reproductions of money, an enforcement agency was formed, the Secret Service. including photographs of money. Along with the law that criminalized reproductions of money, an enforcement agency was formed. The Secret Service. Yeah, those guys with the earpieces, black suits, protect the president, those guys. Today, the agency falls under the Department of Homeland Security.
所有对美国货币的复制品都成了非法的，包括货币的照片。伴随着将复制货币定为犯罪的法律，一个执法机构成立了——特勤局。包括货币的照片。伴随着将复制货币定为犯罪的法律，一个执法机构成立了。特勤局。是的，就是那些戴着耳机、穿着黑西装、保护总统的家伙。今天，该机构隶属于国土安全部。
But at its start in 1865, the Secret Service was part of the Treasury Department, and its only job was to fight counterfeiting. Secret service agents operating from field offices throughout the country have inconsistently fighting the criminals who make voting money as well as those who pass it to the public. That's from a film put out by the Treasury Department in 1945 called Doutful Dollars. 5 called doubtful dollars. Okay, so the ban on any photographic representation of money was in place for about a century. And this was a problem for advertisers and photographers.
但它在 1865 年刚成立时，特勤局是财政部的一部分，其唯一的工作就是打击伪造货币。在全国各地办事处运作的特勤局特工一直在断断续续地打击制造假币的罪犯以及将假币传递给公众的人。这是财政部于 1945 年出品的一部名为《可疑美元》（Doubtful Dollars）的电影中的内容。5 叫做可疑美元。好吧，所以对任何货币摄影再现的禁令大约持续了一个世纪。这对广告商和摄影师来说是个问题。
By the letter of the law, they were specifically barred from taking pictures of money. The law was written before the invention of motion pictures, but when movies came along, it was generally assumed that filmmakers would follow the same rules as photographers. No money on camera. And so in the early days of cinema, when money was needed in a film, producers had to get creative. Thirty, thirty, five, forty, forty-thousand. Shall we stop with forty?
按照法律条文，他们被明确禁止拍摄金钱的照片。这项法律是在电影发明之前编写的，但当电影出现时，人们普遍认为电影制作人会遵循与摄影师相同的规则。镜头前不能出现金钱。因此在电影的早期，当电影中需要金钱时，制片人必须发挥创意。三十、三十五、四十、四十万。我们以四十万停下来好吗？
That's a scene from the 1943 Hitchcock film, Shadow of a Doubt. And if you watch the movie and look closely, you can see that the bills in the scene aren't American dollars. They're Mexican pesos. I'm glad to see that your man who understands the tales of the screen. They're most important to me. Most important. I remember seeing it in movies all the way from the 20s and the 30s and the 40s up into the 70s. This is Peter Huntoun. He's an author and expert on American currency, and he says you can see pesos in a lot of
那是 1943 年希区柯克电影《辣手摧花》（Shadow of a Doubt）中的一个场景。如果你看这部电影并仔细观察，你会发现场景中的钞票不是美元。它们是墨西哥比索。我很高兴看到你是一个懂银幕故事的人。它们对我来说最重要。最重要。我记得从 20 年代、30 年代、40 年代一直到 70 年代，在电影里都看到过这个。这是彼得·亨通（Peter Huntoun）。他是美国货币的作家和专家，他说你可以在很多
old movies. The reason for this is that after the Mexican Revolution ended around 1920, some regional Mexican money that was created during the Revolution lost value and was sold for cheap. The notes from the Mexican state of Chihuahua were Pancho via held power, or some of the most widely used in film. They were absolutely gorgeous because they were multicolored. They had gold, backs, black, print.
老电影中看到比索。原因在于，1920 年墨西哥革命结束后，一些在革命期间创造的地区性墨西哥货币失去了价值，并被廉价出售。来自奇瓦瓦州（Chihuahua）潘乔·维亚（Pancho Villa）掌权时期的墨西哥纸币，是电影中最常使用的纸币之一。它们绝对华丽，因为它们是多色彩的。它们有金色的背面，黑色的印刷。
But the idea was that these things looked like money. They were real nice looking. And so the studio was bought them up. But the studio is weren't trying to pass pesos off as American dollars. It was just all they had. Nobody's ever fooled by it.
但当时的理念是这些东西看起来像钱。它们看起来真的很不错。因此制片厂把它们买了下来。但制片厂并不是想把比索冒充成美元。这只是他们仅有的东西。从来没有人被它愚弄过。
If you see this money go by and a movie, you know whether it's American or not, because of course you'd see that a block away. In the second half of the 20th century, the government began relaxing restrictions on the rules around photographing currency, and it eventually became legal to film real money. And real money is great for scenes where you need close-up shots, like this scene from the 1995 movie Dead Presidents. In this scene, four of the characters have robbed an armored truck and are splitting up the cash.
如果你在电影中看到这些钱流过，你知道它是美国的还是别的什么，因为你当然在很远的地方就能看出来。在 20 世纪下半叶，政府开始放松对拍摄货币规则的限制，最终拍摄真钱变得合法了。对于需要特写镜头的场景来说，真钱是非常棒的，比如 1995 年电影《死去的总统》（Dead Presidents）中的这个场景。在这个场景中，四个角色抢劫了一辆运钞车并正在分赃。
The camera pans slowly over stacks of bills. But it can also be risky to have real money floating around on set, especially if you need a bunch of it. So a lot of producers prefer to use fake money. These days, the government does allow for some reproductions of US currency. It's just not very clear how real fake money can look. It depends. It's very subjective. If it's the same size as a current US currency note and it's front and back and it's made in the likeness of our US currency, then we viewed as counterfeit.
镜头缓慢地掠过一叠叠钞票。但在片场周围带着真钱也可能是有风险的，特别是如果你需要一大堆真钱的时候。因此，许多制片人更喜欢使用假钱。如今，政府确实允许对美国货币进行一些复制。只是不太清楚假的美元可以看起来有多真。这取决于情况。这是非常主观的。如果它的大小与当前美国流通的纸币相同，并且有正反面，并且是仿照我们的美国货币制作的，那么我们就将其视为假币。
That's Trent Everett. I am an assistant to the Special Agent in Charge for our criminal investigative division of the Secret Service, and I currently oversee our counterfeit operations section. Over the years, prop money and movies has begun to look more like actual money, sometimes too much like actual money. Sometimes too much like actual money. Some companies did and still do turn out bills that run a foul of the law. Because to look good on screen, fake money has to be pretty close to the real thing. These movie companies like to have things look as real as possible
那是特伦特·埃弗雷特（Trent Everett）。我是特勤局刑事调查部门的助理特工主管，我目前负责我们的假币打击部门。多年来，电影中的道具钱开始看起来更像真正的钱，有时甚至太像真正的钱了。有时甚至太像真正的钱了。一些公司过去和现在仍在生产触犯法律的钞票。为了在银幕上看起来好看，假钱必须非常接近真品。这些电影公司喜欢让事情看起来尽可能真实
and that's where they start running into issues. Some people make bills that are the same size as real money, but with one or two small design changes, like maybe it says, in dog we trust instead of in god we trust, or has Benjamin Franklin make it a weird face, or there are bills that look exactly like the real thing, except they're stamped with a small disclaimer. All of these would probably be unacceptable to the Secret Service. Remember Greg Bilston from Reshauer 2?
这就是他们开始遇到问题的地方。有些人制作的钞票大小与真钱相同，但有一两个小的设计改动，比如上面可能写着“我们信赖狗狗”（in dog we trust）而不是“我们信仰上帝”（in god we trust），或者让本杰明·富兰克林做出奇怪的表情，或者有些钞票看起来和真品一模一样，除了上面盖有一个小的免责声明。所有这些对特勤局来说可能都是不可接受的。还记得《尖峰时刻 2》中的格雷格·比尔森吗？
He thought they had made their fake bills look different enough from the Secret Service. Remember Greg Bilston from Rush Hour 2? He thought they had made their fake bills look different enough from the real thing. There's probably 25 or 26 separate things that are not what a real $100 bill has on it, but it was still too close to the reality for them to accept. Bilston had to turn over all of his prop money to the Secret Service to be destroyed. And then they confiscated and destroyed all the electronic files that were used and
他以为他们的假钞做得和特勤局的真币有足够的区别。还记得《尖峰时刻 2》中的格雷格·比尔森吗？他以为他们的假钞做得和真品有足够的区别。可能有 25 或 26 个不同的地方与真正的 100 美元纸币不符，但它与现实太接近了，以至于他们无法接受。比尔森不得不将他所有的道具钱交出来给特勤局销毁。然后他们没收并销毁了用于
creating this money. Wilson lost a lot of money. Not just the fake money, but the real money it took to produce the fake money. Oh, it was well in excess of $100,000. Just the paper stock alone to buy enough paper to produce a billion dollars was $77,000. In the end, all Wilsonson really lost was money. He didn't have to go to jail. These days, he mostly tries to avoid using fake money at all.
制作这些钱的所有电子文件。威尔森损失了很多钱。不仅是假钱，还有生产假钱所需的真钱。哦，这远远超过了 100,000 美元。单单是购买足够生产十亿美元的纸张库存就花了 77,000 美元。最后，威尔森真正失去的只是钱。他不必坐牢。如今，他基本上尽量避免使用假钱。
It's just too hard to please both the Secret Service and the movie producers. It's not worth it. I'm not going to break the law for a TV show, a feature film, or a producer that I don't even know. But movies are definitely not the only way fake money is making it into the marketplace. Here's Trent Everett again from the Secret Service. That's not that it's just leaking out of production companies, but that's being sold on the internet or anybody can purchase it. You can actually buy prop money right now on Amazon. It's even on Prime, free, two-day shipping.
要同时取悦特勤局和电影制片人实在是太难了。不值得。我不会为了一个电视节目、一部故事片或一个我甚至不认识的制片人去违法。但电影绝对不是假钱进入市场的唯一途径。这里又是来自特勤局的特伦特·埃弗雷特。这不仅是从制作公司泄露出去，而且是在互联网上出售，任何人都可以购买。你现在实际上可以在亚马逊上买到道具钱。它甚至还在 Prime 上，免费的两日达配送。
So of course, we ordered some. Yep, this is it. That's producer Katie Mingle opening up the package. Okay, so it's a little stack about half an inch thick. It does look a good bit like money from a distance. It doesn't feel that much like money though. It feels like just regular paper to me. Benjamin Franklin is making a really strange face. It's like they took his mouth and shrunk it. And it says, for motion picture use only, but yeah, let me see if I can fool any of my coworkers at this.
所以我们当然订购了一些。是的，就是这个。那是制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）在打开包裹。好吧，它是一小叠，大约半英寸厚。从远处看，它确实很像钱。不过摸起来感觉不太像钱。我觉得它摸起来就像普通纸一样。本杰明·富兰克林的表情真的很奇怪。就像他们把他的嘴拿掉并缩小了一样。上面写着“仅限影视使用”，但是，好吧，让我看看我能不能用这个愚弄我的任何同事。
Katie has about $10 dollar bills in her hands, which she's going to say a fan sent us in the mail. Oh my god, you guys. A fan just sent us this note with all this money in it. Who did? A fan. Just sent us the radio to me. It just says, Dear 99 Chi,
凯蒂手里大约有 10 美元的钞票，她打算说这是粉丝在邮件里寄给我们的。天哪，你们。一个粉丝刚刚给我们寄了这张纸条，里面有这么多钱。谁干的？一个粉丝。刚刚把电台寄给我。上面写着，亲爱的 99 Chi，
Oh my god, that's so much money. I love your work. Please treat yourself to something special when I am just people. How much money is it? Is this real? This isn't real. Promotion picture use only. Shut up.
天哪，那是好多钱啊。我喜欢你们的工作。请用它好好犒劳一下自己，而我只是一般人。这是多少钱？这是真的吗？这不是真的。仅供影视使用。闭嘴。
OK, so Delaney could see it was fake as soon as it was in her hand. But from a couple of feet away, the money does look really convincing. And Trent Everett told me they're actually investigating some fake money that looks a lot like the stuff you guys bought from Amazon. Currently, we are investigating the motion picture note that has been popping up all over e-commerce sites, but it's too cited. It is similar size. It is in the likeness of a $100 US note.
好吧，所以德兰尼（Delaney）一拿到手就能看出它是假的。但从几英尺远的地方看，这钱看起来确实非常逼真。特伦特·埃弗雷特告诉我，他们实际上正在调查一些看起来很像你们从亚马逊买的那些假钱。目前，我们正在调查在各大电商网站上不断涌现的影视纸币，但它的确被引用了。它的尺寸相似。它是模仿面额 100 美元的美国纸币制作的。
And the only difference on it is that it says motion picture. You so only. So don't be surprised if some secret service agent show up at the 99PI offices. No charges necessarily. We brought on the person for purchasing it. They just aren't legally able to possess it. Okay, just for the record, the person who purchased it, it's Katie Mangle.
上面唯一的区别是它写着“仅限影视使用”。所以如果有些特工出现在 99PI 的办公室里，不要感到惊讶。不一定会提出指控。我们把购买它的人请来。他们只是在法律上不能持有它。好吧，郑重声明，购买它的人是凯蒂·明格尔。
M-I-N-G-L-E. Given how difficult it is to make money that looks real but not too real, it's hard to imagine who still wants to be in the business of creating and supplying fake money for the movies. But there are a few people still doing it, including RJ Rappaport. I'm Rich RJ Rappaport, and I'm the president of RJer Props. We are a props house for film, television, music industry, commercials, and the entertainment industry. When I visit RJ at work, he shows me around a huge warehouse. There are all kinds of different props.
M-I-N-G-L-E。鉴于制作看起来真实但又不过于逼真的钱是多么困难，很难想象谁还会愿意从事为电影创造和供应假钱的行业。但仍有一些人这样做，包括 RJ·拉帕波特（RJ Rappaport）。我是里奇·RJ·拉帕波特，我是 RJer Props 的总裁。我们是电影、电视、音乐产业、商业广告和娱乐行业的道具公司。当我拜访工作的 RJ 时，他带我参观了一个巨大的仓库。里面有各种各样的道具。
A hospital bed, a prison cell, a futuristic machine with lots of knobs and buttons. We've got giant control panels like this. Blue lights spinning across circuit boards and flashing LEDs and all sorts of interesting things. RJ's been in this business for years, but he's still seems so excited by it. It's almost like he's a kid playing pretend with all the perfect toys. For instance, if somebody had to disarm this, it's the
一张医院病床、一间牢房、一台带有许多旋钮和按钮的未来主义机器。我们有像这样巨大的控制面板。蓝色的灯光在电路板上旋转，闪烁着 LED，还有各种各样有趣的东西。RJ 从事这一行已经很多年了，但他看起来仍然对它充满热情。这几乎就像一个孩子用所有完美的玩具在玩过家家。例如，如果有人必须解除这个武装，它是
missile control system. Not the missile control system. Yes, the missile control system. Not the missile control system. Yes, the missile control system. Cut the red wire. Okay, cutting the red wire. Now the blue wire. When we step into the room with the prop money, it's like seeing a bunch of movie clichés side by side. There are stacks and stacks of bills
导弹控制系统。不是导弹控制系统？是的，导弹控制系统。不是导弹控制系统？是的，导弹控制系统。剪断红线。好的，剪断红线。现在是蓝线。当我们走进存放道具钱的房间时，就像看到了一堆并排的电影陈词滥调。这里有一叠又一叠的钞票
wrapped with paper bands like they just came from the bank. So I noticed you also have a briefcase of money. Is that one whole prop that you give out the briefcase with the stacks of cash in? It is. This is an entire prop ready to go. And we have other briefcases like this. It's a black leather briefcase.
用纸带绑着，就像刚从银行拿出来一样。所以我注意到你还有一个装钱的手提箱。那是你连同装有现金的成叠纸钞一起发出的整个道具吗？是的。这是一个随时可以使用的完整道具。我们还有其他这样的手提箱。这是一个黑色的皮质手提箱。
And this is a brown leather briefcase. Sometimes we fill them with fake drugs as well. RJ says it took three years of back and forth between him and the Secret Service to agree on a design for prop money. That kind of guidance isn't something the Secret Service normally provides, by the way. RJ managed to finagle an exception. We worked with the Secret Service and we went over all of the laws, all of the updates,
这是一个棕色的皮质手提箱。有时我们也会在里面装满假毒品。RJ 说，他与特勤局之间经过了三年的来回沟通，才就道具钱的设计达成一致。顺便说一句，这种指导通常不是特勤局提供的。RJ 设法争取到了一个特例。我们与特勤局合作，我们研究了所有的法律、所有的更新、
all of the changes. It's a very tedious process where you're just doing original artwork from scratch. R.J. says when he makes bills that are blank on one side, he can make them pretty realistic. But otherwise, you have to be really careful. Jump through a ton of hoops. And even then, sometimes the Secret Service
所有的变化。这是一个非常乏味的过程，你只是从头开始制作原创艺术品。RJ 说，当他制作单面空白的钞票时，他可以把它们做得非常逼真。但除此之外，你必须非常小心。经历重重困难。即便如此，有时特勤局
will end up asking you to destroy everything you've made. It's so much hassle that, ironically, there's no money in it. And it's not a big money maker. No joke intended. It's not the way that we make a living. It's really not. This is really just a service that we do for our clients. And we know that if they're going to come back to us for something bigger and better, then we'll make a living on that.
最终还是会要求你销毁你制作的一切。这太麻烦了，具有讽刺意味的是，这根本赚不到钱。这不是一个赚钱的大项目。绝对没有开玩笑的意思。这不是我们谋生的方式。真的不是。这真的只是我们为客户提供的一项服务。我们知道，如果他们为了更大更好的东西再次找到我们，那我们就会靠那个谋生。
RJ has supplied money for a bunch of popular movies and TV shows, like the Netflix series Ozark. Okay. Money laundering 101. So you come across a suitcase with 5 million bucks in it. In this scene, there's a montage that includes cash on a glass table, cash running through a county machine, and cash in a suitcase. The IRS won't let you buy anything of value with it.
RJ 为许多受欢迎的电影和电视剧提供过钱，比如 Netflix 电视剧《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）。好的。洗钱入门。所以你偶然发现了一个装有 500 万美元的手提箱。在这个场景中，有一个蒙太奇镜头，包括玻璃桌上的现金、点钞机里运转的现金以及手提箱里的现金。国税局不会让你用它买任何有价值的东西。
TV and movies are full of characters who come across suitcases full of money. It's a fun plot device. But behind all this cash is someone like RJ, who has been through a meticulous design process and years of back and forth with the Secret Service. Because for the film producers, there's no such thing as easy money. You know what's not on US currency? A dollar symbol. Kurt explores the origin of the S with a line through it after this.
电视和电影里到处都是偶然发现装满钱的手提箱的角色。这是一个有趣的剧情设定。但在所有这些现金背后，都有像 RJ 这样的人，他经历过细致的设计过程，并与特勤局进行了多年的来回交涉。因为对于电影制作人来说，根本没有所谓的轻而易举的钱。你知道美国货币上没有的是什么吗？美元符号。接下来，库尔特（Kurt）将探讨带有一条竖线的 S 的起源。
So I'm in the studio with Digital Director Kurt Colstead. And as we mentioned earlier, when those really strict anti-counterfeiting laws were on the books, movies used pesos to stand in for US currency. But the idea of seeing pesos circulating in the United States wasn't actually all that new or crazy back then. Yeah, in fact, from the late 1700s, all the way up to 1857, Paisels were legal tender in the United States. And around the same time that Congress officially approved their use, the dollar sign started to appear. And so where did the dollar sign come from?
所以我现在和数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）在录音室里。正如我们之前提到的，当那些极其严格的反造假法律出台时，电影曾用比索来代替美国货币。但当时在美利坚合众国看到比索流通的想法实际上并不是那么新奇或疯狂。是的，事实上，从 18 世纪末一直到 1857 年，比索在美国是法定货币。就在国会正式批准使用它们的同时，美元符号开始出现。那么美元符号是从哪里来的呢？
Well, nobody's really sure who first designed the dollar sign, and there's a lot of intriguing theories about how it came about. Some people have speculated that the S, with the double lines, those two vertical lines over it, is actually a U superimposed on an S, but with the bottom of the U removed. So it's supposed to be U S as in U S currency. Right, and that's an appealing theory in theory. I mean, it makes the dollar sign seem distinctively American, like a national symbol,
嗯，没有人真正确定是谁首先设计了美元符号，关于它是如何产生的有很多有趣的理论。有些人推测，带有双条纹、即上面有两条垂直线条的 S，实际上是一个叠加在 S 上的 U，但去掉了 U 的底部。所以它应该是 U S，代表美国货币。没错，理论上这是一个很有吸引力的理论。我的意思是，这使得美元符号看起来具有独特的美国特色，就像一个国家标志一样，
but it's widely believed to be false at this point. Okay, so that's one hypothesis. What's your favorite version of how the dollar sign came to be? Well, there's this rather epic theory that the dollar sign traces back to the pillars of Hercules on either side of the Strait of Gibraltar. This famous Strait is effectively the threshold between the Mediterranean Sea and the Atlantic Ocean, and according to legend, the flanking pillars were once inscribed with the Latin words non-pluse ultra, which translates as nothing further beyond.
但在这一点上，人们普遍认为这是假的。好吧，这是一个假设。对于美元符号是如何诞生的，你最喜欢哪个版本？嗯，有一个相当史诗般的理论，认为美元符号可以追溯到直布罗陀海峡两旁的赫拉克勒斯之柱（Pillars of Hercules）。这个著名的海峡实际上是地中海和大西洋之间的门槛，根据传说，两侧的柱子上曾经刻有拉丁文“non-pluse ultra”，翻译过来就是“再无前方”。
Oh, is in once you leave the Mediterranean Sea, there is nothing beyond there, just the endless ocean. Right. This is the end of the world as we know it, and that motto ended up on old Spanish currency. But it was later changed when Christopher Columbus reached America. They actually dropped the non-part and made it pluse ultra, meaning further beyond. To reflect this new realization, that in fact, there was a lot more to the world out there. And on Spanish coinage, the motto was shown on banners
哦，意思是只要你离开地中海，那里就没有别的了，只有无尽的海洋。没错。这是我们所知的世界末日，这个座右铭最终出现在了古代西班牙货币上。但后来当克里斯托弗·哥伦布到达美洲时，它被改变了。他们实际上删掉了“non”部分，将其改为“pluse ultra”，意思是“更进一步”。为了反映这一新的认识，即实际上外面还有更多世界。在西班牙硬币上，座右铭显示在
that wrapped a flanking pair of Ornate pillars. So you have this kind of eschaped banner that winds down around a vertical column. So in other words, with a pillar and a banner wrapped around it, it looks like the single line dollar sign. Pretty much. And it's a fun story, but the prevailing theory is actually that the dollar sign was never really about the new world. It wasn't something distinctively American. In fact, it all comes back to the Spanish pesos and their plural abbreviation, which is PS. So as I said before, the peso is getting a lot of use
缠绕在一对华丽柱子两侧的横幅上。所以你有一种类似 S 形的横幅，它沿着垂直的柱子缠绕下来。换句话说，有了柱子和缠绕在其上的横幅，它看起来就像单线条的美元符号。差不多。这是一个有趣的故事，但普遍的理论实际上是，美元符号从来都不是关于新世界的。它不是什么具有美国特色的东西。事实上，这一切都可以追溯到西班牙比索及其复数缩写“PS”。正如我之前所说，比索正在被大量使用
the P.S. So as I said before, the pace I was getting a lot of use in American businesses and the 1700s. And the idea is that as it was getting written down over and over again on documents, the P started to overlap with the S and the curve part of the P just got dropped over time. So you end up with something that looks like the single bar dollar sign with that vertical line going up through an S that we know today. And so that is thought to be the true story. It is thought by many to be the true story and that is what the Oxford English Dictionary claims is the true story. But you know, we may never be sure. 99% of visible was produced this week by Elizabeth Nakano, edited by our senior producer Katie Mingle. Sharif Yusuf did the tech production and mix. Sean Real composed the music. Kurt Colstead is the digital director
P.S. 所以正如我之前所说，比索在 18 世纪的美国企业中被广泛使用。这个想法是，当它在文件中被一次又一次地写下来时，P 开始与 S 重叠，而 P 的曲线部分随着时间的推移就被去掉了。所以最终你会得到一个看起来像单条美元符号的东西，中间有一条垂直线穿过我们今天所知的 S。因此，这被认为是真实的故事。许多人认为这是真实的故事，这也是《牛津英语词典》声称的真实故事。但你知道，我们可能永远无法确定。本周的 99% Invisible 是由伊丽莎白·中野（Elizabeth Nakano）制作的，由我们的高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）编辑。谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusuf）负责技术制作和混音。肖恩·雷尔（Sean Real）谱写了音乐。库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，
and the rest of the staff includes Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. This show is part of Radio Topia from PRX, Yo-ro, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. This show is part of radio Tokyo from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows
其他工作人员包括德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、泰伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）和本人罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市市中心的广播街（Radio Row）制作。本节目是 PRX 旗下 Radiootopia 的一部分，好极了，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市市中心。本节目是来自 PRX 的 radio Tokyo 的一部分，它是
in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and sticker-loving listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. If you want to read an article about car-free cities or see our video about biomimicry
播客中最优秀、最具创新性的节目的集合。我们得到了奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）和像您一样热爱贴纸的听众的支持。您可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并参与关于节目的讨论。您也可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars 以及节目@99PI org，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。如果您想阅读关于无车城市的文章，或者观看我们与 Box 合作制作的关于仿生学的视频，
that we made with Box, you have to go to our website. It's 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您必须访问我们的网站。网址是 99PI.org。Radio Tapio。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。